last week Health and Human Services
Secretary Tom Price resigned after
spending four hundred thousand dollars
of taxpayer money on private jets four
hundred thousand dollars yeah yeah now
Trump was furious when he found out
price was charging the government for
private planes yeah President Trump said
hey that's my thing
[Laughter]
[Applause]
poor poor Tom price now he has to fly
first-class commercial like a common
millionaire yeah good one Andy you know
you know your honor you know you're on a
Tom Price flight when the captain says
we all were all clear for ripoff you
know yeah Tom Price is like he yeah Andy
check this out hey Tom Price if I
screwed that many taxpayers I checked
myself for STDs sorry are you are you
okay Andy has that ever happened to you
you're trading clips with a friend and
then suddenly you draw a blank you can't
think of anything funny to say look at
me I've got nothing
well good thing there's the quick wit
app quick wit listens to all your
conversations and automatically compiles
dozens of puns word plays insults
comebacks and sex references related to
your topic so don't be a nitwit just
quick win sorry are you you sure you're
okay Andy yeah I was just thinking about
Tom price he had to resign but he gets
to keep his frequent liar miles
Goodwin Andy Goodwin
thanks going in and thank you quick wit
I can't make it stop
[Applause]
[Applause]
you okay all right I'm gonna try and do
the rest of the show with those guys
right there
[Laughter]
you